since Friday Jet Airways staff have been
staging demonstrations they're calling
for the Indian government to intervene
and they want lenders to find a way to
rescue the carrier please save our
airline it was one of the premier
airline and we are facing a lot of
difficulties just we are we are families
to Jet Airways is billions of dollars in
debt and it now desperately needs
another cash injection thousands of
flights have been cancelled with little
or no notice for passengers the airline
doesn't have enough planes Jet Airways
says it has an overall fleet of 119
aircraft but the number of planes has
plummeted to just seven the carrier has
been unable to pay aircraft leases on
time they're well below the Indian
regulators minimum requirement of 20
aircraft for any carrier operating
international flights Airways employees
fear any rescue could be too late Jet
Airways staff aren't the only ones who
fear losing jobs of the airline tumbles
for Prime Minister Narendra Modi who is
running for re-election getting the
needed votes may depend on finding a
buyer for the beleaguered airline in
time let's talk about that without
ratash Pandey is following this story
for us Ashutosh just how important is
fixing this problem for Modi's
reelection bid well honestly it's not
going to have much of an impact on his
political fortunes it's more about
perception or sending the right message
so Prime Minister Larry Modi would not
want a prominent airline that employs
more than 20,000 employees to go bust
under his watch I mean he has actually
boasted all about his
pro-business credentials all through the
past five years and even before that
when he was the chief minister for
province in India so having said that he
wouldn't want that to happen
under his watch and that's the reason
why we are seeing state-owned banks
coming to the rescue of a private
company
it's a rare move by a state-owned a bank
and a consortium led by a consortium of
banks led by the State Bank of India
wasn't this one of thee O Lord the
biggest airlines at its time at its
height bye-bye market share and what
went wrong well it did not anticipate
back then that there would be this
sudden rise of low-cost budget airlines
and once they came in like Airlines like
indigo Spice Jet jet could it was always
left playing the SketchUp game okay so
it did bring down its fares but it
continued to operate as a full-service
carrier as a result it took up a lot of
debt around a billion per dollar worth
of debts and hence the condition that we
find the dis Airways today in all so
what did not help a Jet Airways cause
was the volatile crude oil prices well
that has actually hurt the entire
aviation sector of fast-growing aviation
sector in India touted to be the third
largest aviation market in the world in
the coming five to ten years so but Jet
Airways weight-loss tower was the fact
that it could not catch up and it always
kept playing the SketchUp game okay so
it took a long time for it to try
catching up but never did yeah and now
it's in financial trouble and you've got
all of these pilots who haven't even
been paid why is it taking so long to
fix this problem well I believe the jet
taught all this while that it could
actually weather the storm as it has
done in the past few years it has
actually managed to weather the storm
but there's also an important factor and
that is its founder nourish coil now
that is goal was reluctant in the first
place to give give up control of Jet
Airways and and that actually dissuaded
many potential investors to actually
make some investment in Jet Airways he
did not want to give up control of the
air base now he has given up control and
hence we
this debt restructuring deal and the SBI
older consortium led consortium has
taken control hopefully there would be a
solution to this but experts are not
very optimistic at this point of time
because the the consortium hasn't
actually infused or given the money that
it has promised so far and hence the
meeting today that they're discussing
about whether it could actually give a
part of the some it had promised a
waiting game the waiting game continues
yeah absolutely
Ashutosh thank you very much for coming
in